[Music]
[Music]
so it's always a big event when naughty
dog releases a new game they've proven
time and time again that they have
somewhat mastered the craft of
storytelling in games not the least of
which with uncharted 4 they've done in a
lot of ways it's hard to look back and
uncharted now and imagine it without
uncharted for Randi can you talk about
the problems they addressed between the
first three games and also just how
they've addressed the character of
Nathan Drake you mentioned that the
first three Uncharted games you know if
you want to be really reductive about
the previous games you could say that
you know the stories of them are all the
same which is essentially you know
Nathan Drake goes at tries to find the
treasure eventually loses it but in the
end realizes that the only treasure he
needs is his relationship that
particularly with Elena and you could
say the same thing about uncharted 4 you
know like at its you know at its core
that is what it's about but you know I
think this game out of any of the
Uncharted games is the one that actually
delivers a proper character arc for
Nathan you know the ending of this thing
does move Nathan Drake forward as a
character it moves the relationship with
him and Elena forward and I think it
also answers a lot of those questions
about you know Drake's character in the
first three games in which you know he
was a you know a massive dick to Elena
and to all of his friends but you know
by the end of this thing that second
epilogue I think sort of like bought the
whole series together and it felt like a
really natural endpoint for for Nathan
and for for the series yeah you
mentioned Drake's relationship with
other characters and I think that's a
high point for uncharted 4 you know you
have new characters like nadie and Ross
Rafe Adler and then of course Nathan
Drake's brother Sam who kind of felt
like we thought he might be shoehorned
right like just bringing this brother we
didn't know about but it turns out Elena
didn't even know about him this is a
secret Drake's kept since he was a kid
this is Sam
Sam Drake my brother
[Music]
you you could think that uncharted for
going in that it would just be over
stuff with characters you have three
games of previous characters that you're
trying to shoehorn in on top of all
these new characters but it's a
testament to their storytelling that
they make all of them feel essential
particularly drake's brother and
grounding that making that feel like not
only is his brother a real character
that you believe that this is something
that he's kind of kept secret but also
the that it makes Drake feel more real
that it really strengthens his character
arc and it makes him more believable
both at some of the horrible things that
he's done but also makes his redemption
in some ways it makes that all more real
yeah of course there's always a
cinematic flair to Naughty Dog's games
the way they choose the teller store
isn't a narrative that shape them you
know between uncharred one two three and
then of course the Last of Us uncharted
4 seems to be the culmination of that
between these sweeping vistas beating
these cutscenes and out of these
cutscenes there's just such a great way
they've approached showing the story to
us I think they're really our masters
now Naughty Dog do really are masters
now of you know showing narrative
through actions so they're not telling
you the story just when does a cutscene
available they're actually showing you
that through what the character and you
are doing and you know one of my
favorite sections in this game was
really early on when you know Nathan was
upstairs in his house in his attic and
he was basically playing around with a
lot of memorabilia that he'd collected
over the past weekend and at that stage
of the story you know like the the
narrative was telling you that Nathan
wasn't going to go out and go on another
adventure
but in playing through that level you
just got an insight into his thinking
and that yeah you know he actually still
misses that you know he's looking at all
this stuff and he really wants to go out
there for one last run
they come take cover right bullseye
yeah and you see these little kind of
like winks between characters even just
like a way that Alena looks at Drake
when he's going on this rave about this
pirate legend Avery you know like you
get the sense that she realized at some
point that some things are part of the
character and he can't change but they
can kind of work together to do that and
this is all told through these like
subtle nods to the player
it's incredible I'm sorry yeah I'm sorry
it's okay
but Naughty Dog is also really good at
telling that story in the gameplay you
don't always have to kill everyone in
this game you do have to kill a few
people but a lot of the areas whether
you're in Madagascar Scotland are kind
of these sandbox they let you approach
whether you want to be kind of more
stealthy or you want to just start
shooting right away I think Uncharted
has always had really salted mechanics
you know once well two through hit two
and three were we're really good as far
as combining that gunplay the
storytelling but but they would always
get bogged down by making you have to
murder lots and lots of people before
you can progress on to the next point
the Last of Us they fixed a lot of those
problems where they they combined this
stealth element and the way that the
buildings in the the world is put
together along with your ability to
traverse it and then I was so happy that
they took those lessons over to
uncharted 4 that it's not just a world
that you can explore that it's not a
huge open place that you're trying to
find new things in but it does feel real
and it does feel like you have a choice
like you do have to kill some people but
you're not the murderous crazy person
that you were in previous games like you
it feels like when I have to kill
somebody that's necessary but a lot of
the time I can find a way to get around
this if I want to look around a level be
stealthy be quiet I can get out of this
situation without learning literally
everybody to where I am
yeah in almost every aspect uncharted 4
just say hits a home run as far as
storytelling I think
gameplay just really facilitates this
narrative that going for the new
characters the relationships it's always
an event when a naughty again releases
but uncharted for not just for the
problems it corrected with the entire
series but just making it a superb game
in its own right and now looking back at
the Uncharted franchise I can't imagine
it without uncharted 4 and that is why
it is almost at the top of our list at
the number two spot for GameSpot's
2016 best of Cheers
[Music]